اكثروا ماسك اذا زياره يتم كوك مجددا
قريبا في ابل بارك سنستبق هذه الزياره
المحتمله وسناخذكم الى ما كان يوما حلما
وتحول الى حقيقه
لدينا الفرصه لبناء افضل مبنى اداريا في
العالم كلماته ستيف جوبز مؤسس شركه ابل
نحن في سيليكون بالي في ولايه كاليفورنيا
شركه ابل افتتح للموظفين في ابريل من
العام 2017
80% من هذا المبنى يتكون من مساحات خضراء
تسعه الاف الشجره في حرم المبنى المياه
المعادوا تدميرها وتستخدم في اي هذه
الاشجار
وان ياتي طلاب الهندسه المعماريه لدراسته
يلقب المبنى لسفينه الفضاء لتصميمه
الدائري الذي يشبه الصحن الطائر
اراده ستيف جوبز ان يجعل المقر الرئيسي
لابل مشابهه
القيمه السوقيه للشركه الى ترميوني دولار
رقم ضخم كالمبنى الذي نشاهده هنا اكبر من
بلداننا كثيره حول العالم المبنى الرئيسي
اللي قتل واحد من اغلى مقر الشركات في
الولايات المتحده خمسه مليارات دولار
تكلفه تشيده بحسبه بسيطه كله قدما مربع
تقريبا كلف نحو الف و
175$ تبلغ مساحه هذا المبنى المركزي
260,000 متر مربع وبداخله
يعمل واكثر من اثني عشر الفا موظف لكن
هناك حقيقه قد لا يعلمها الكثيرون داخل
هناك مركز زوار وهو مفتوح مجانا
الدخول الى هنا
المبنى يعد احد اكثر المباني كفاءه في
استخدام الطاقه في العالم المبنى الرئيسي
مسرح السيف جوبز مركز اللياقه البدنيه
كلها حاصله على شهاده الرياده في تصميمات
الطاقه والبيئه من فئه البلاتينيه
2018 تحولت للتشغيل الكامل بالطاقه
المتجدده
للالواح الشمسيه المثبته على سطح الحرم ان
تولد 17 ميجا بايت من الطاقه وهو ما يكفي
لتزويد 75% من الطاقه خلال ذروه النهار ما
يجعل هذا السطح احد اكبر الاسطح الشمسيه
في العالم